[Music]
hello everyone my name is nari sol and
today i'm working on creating an
exercise using broken six that will also
be a little jazzy and a little
reminiscent of stride piano and i'd like
to just walk you through the process and
show you
where i'm drawing my material from and
how i'm putting it all together so this
is the beginning of beethoven sonata
opus 10 number three
so this pattern is made up of six
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so two five one so at first i was
thinking of applying this harmony
but then i changed my mind to something
a little
less cadence-like and something that i
could just go through different keys
so now i'm looking at this pattern where
i'm applying the broken six
[Music]
but something about it seems a little
boring
i'm gonna change that
[Music]
so i'm going to switch up the pattern so
that the direction changes a little more
often
[Music]
so for the second part of this group i
think i want to do something that is not
broken sixths
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so thank you very much for watching if
you'd like to get a hold of a written
out version of this exercise i'll
include the link in the description
below
and i'll see you in the next video
[Music]